dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly life ahead it is time
for some minds to be blown dota 2 is a
multiplayer online battle arena game
with a huge cult following and World
Championship events with a prize pool of
over 20 million dollars in this game
players form two teams and control a
hero each and use their strategy and
special abilities to defeat the other
team open AI who recently created an AI
for this game that is so good that they
challenged the best players in the world
now note that this program is not
playing the full feature set of the game
but a version that is limited to one
versus one encounters with several other
elements of the game disabled since lots
of strategy is involved we always
discuss in these episodes that long-term
planning is the Achilles heel of these
learning algorithms a small blunder in
the early game can often snowball out of
control by the end of the match and it
is hard for the AI and sometimes to even
humans to identify these cases and this
game is a huge challenge because unlike
chess and go it has lots of incomplete
information and even the simplified 1vs1
mode involves a reasonable amount of
long-term planning it also involves
attacks trickery and deceiving an
opponent and can be imagined as a
strategy game that also requires
significant technical prowess to pull
off the most spectacular moves this game
is also designed in a way that new and
unfamiliar situations come up all the
time which require lots of experience
and split-second decision-making to
master this is a true test for any kind
of AI and note that this AI wasn't told
anything about the game
not even the rules and was just
instructed to try to find a way to win
the algorithm was trained in 24 hours
and during this time it not only learned
the rules and objectives of the game but
it also pulls off remarkable tactics for
instance other players were very
surprised that the bots didn't take the
bait which typically means a smart
tactic involving giving up a smaller
battle
in favor of winning a bigger objective
the AI has a ton of experience playing
the game and typically sees through
these shenanigans in this game there are
also neutral units that we call creep
when killed they grant precious gold and
experience to our opponent so we
typically try to deny that if these
units encounter an obstacle they go
around it so players develop the
technique by the name creep blocking
which is the art of holding them up by
the hero character to minimize the
distance traveled by them in a unit of
time and the AI has not only learned
about the existence of this technique by
itself but it also executed with
stunning precision which is quite
remarkable and again during the training
phase it had never seen any human play
the game and do something like this the
other remarkable thing is that when a
player disappears in the darkness the AI
predicts what he could be doing plans
around it and strikes where the player
is expected to show up if you remember
deep Minds initial go algorithm
contained the bootstrapping step where
it was fed a large amount of games by
players to grasp the basics the truly
remarkable thing is that none of that
happened here the algorithm was trained
for only 24 hours and it only played
against itself when it finally played
against dandy the reigning world
champion the first match was such a
treat and I was shocked to see that the
AI has outplayed him in the second game
the player tried to create a situation
that he thought the AI hasn't
encountered before by giving up some
crit to it the program ruthlessly took
advantage of this mistake and defeated
him almost immediately open es bought
not only one but apparently also broke
the will of dandy who tapped out after
two matches
[Music]
[Applause]
I can hear you now den do we control it
I give up
giving up yeah I don't think I'm skiing
is like break is that sweet alright it's
gonna drop me I've seen this quite a lot
this week okay so what you want to do
like that's to our five or your outfit
I feel like someone being hit by a
sledgehammer I didn't even know this was
being worked on this is such a
remarkable achievement usually the first
argument I hear is that of course the a
I can play non-stop without bathroom
breaks or sleep while admittedly this is
also true for some players the algorithm
was only trained for 24 hours
note that the still means a stupendous
amount of games played but in terms of
training time given that these
algorithms typically take from weeks to
months to train properly 24 hours is
nothing the second argument that I often
hear is that the AI should of course win
every time because it has close to zero
reaction time and can perform thousands
of actions every second for instance if
we would play a game where the goal is
to perform the most amount of actions
per minute clearly humans with
biological limitations would stand no
chance against the computer program
however in this case the number of
actions that this algorithm performs in
a minute is comparable to that of a
human player this means that these
results stem from superior technical
abilities and planning and not from the
fact that we are talking about the
computer we can look at this result from
two different directions one could be
saying well no big deal because this is
only a highly limited and hamstrung
version of the game which is way less
complex than the fully fleshed 5vs5 team
match or two we could say that the
algorithm had shown a remarkable
aptitude for learning highly
sophisticated technical maneuvers and
longer-term strategy in a difficult game
and the rest is only a matter of time in
fact in five versus five there is even
more room for a highly intelligent
program to shine and create new tactics
that we've never thought of I would bet
that if anything we are going to be even
more surprised by the five versus five
results later we are still lacking in
details of it but I have contacted the
open AI guys who noted that there will
be more information available in the
next few days whenever something new
appears I'll be here to cover it for you
fellow scholars
if you're new to the series and enjoyed
this episode make sure to subscribe and
click the bell icon for two super fun
science videos a week and if you find
yourself interested in dota 2 and
admittedly it's hard not to and would
like to catch up a bit on the basics
make sure to visit the 9th channel who
has a really nice playlist about the
fundamentals of the game there's a link
in the description for it check it out
if you go to his channel make sure to
live in a kind scholarly comment let the
world see how courteous the two minute
papers listeners are thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
you